we are Kingsman an international  intelligence agency operating at the  highest level of discretion well most of  the time I think I max as a true reason  for going to the cinema  it's about a working-class Street kid  being turned into the new modern  gentleman spy to help save a lot and the  man who got your release eggs he's kind  of drifted over to the wrong side of the  tracks with me and Harry wants to take  the challenge that he can mold this boy  into the kingdom and materials I'm  offering you the opportunity to become a  Kingsman agent is it of course not I  just saw this on an IMAX screen and for  me it makes me feel like a young kid  again you watch the film like that going  wow wow wow as I've well assembled the  Kingsmen  cinemas should be big and epic and you  get transported into another world  sorry love go save the world go and have  an experience that they've probably  never had before 9 message said I'll see  a few things I've never seen before  you